they're more than just what played
between our favorite childhood Saturday
morning cartoons drove public service
announcements have been a part of your
life and a part of your nightmares for
decades join us as we count down five
more drug PSAs that tried to scare the
[ __ ] out of us but didn't number 5 is
straight-up drugs
yep during the Golden Age of rap music
the partnership for drug-free America
was capitalizing on the music genre with
some of the scariest rhymes you've ever
heard thrown down the sad fact is that
this video really delivers on the
promise that a lot of young black males
will go to jail for petty drug crimes
and have their lives ruined by harsh
criminal justice number 4 Sonny and Cher
the pot if you become a pothead you risk
blowing the most important time of your
life you're a teenage if anyone is gonna
tell you not to do drugs
let it be gold jumpsuits Sonny Bono well
you're up and grass you may tell
yourself only what you want to know if
you are lucky enough not to be on a bad
trip
this PSA is a part of a longer film that
starts with police raiding a party full
of hipsters smoking pot no one has the
right tell me what I can do with my old
body they shout pretty convincing
arguments in favor of legalizing the
drug and then Bono refutes them
throughout the film
maybe it's the future congressman
slurred speech or his bloodshot eyes you
never get the feeling that his heart is
really in it though let's hear for those
other teenagers for smoking pot number
three is doctor drugs
what if the joint we're in somebody
else's hand that's pretty scary right
like your surgeon your lawyer or your
local policeman would you still say
marijuana is harmless I guess you should
have thought twice about going to that
free clinic surgeon where you can
apparently freely smoke pot in the
operating room number two crece karate
Turtles we've all been offered we'd like
this right but did you ever ask yourself
what would the Ninja Turtles do yep when
the Ninja Turtles are not fighting
shredder they're not at all doing drugs
not at all she's right drug dealers
you're dorks
don't even talk to him so when in doubt
take advice from the talking turtle
ninjas who have addictive personalities
and sound like your college roommate
number one the snake dealer you know who
I am
snake dealing and weed coke crack your
choice take one hit and you'll do
anything the popcorn see you can't see
the drug dealer who's talking to you
until now some folks will tell you that
I'm dealing in poison but hey do I look
like the kind of guy that would do that
to a kid like you yeah he's a goddamn
man with a snake head yes okay good well
there you go all five if you aren't high
by now post some links to more drug PSAs
in the comment section below